10 billion dollars then 47 billion than
100 billion the adani group's seven
listed companies have plummeted in
market value after a report from short
seller Hindenburg research accused the
conglomerate of wide-ranging fraud the
adani group headed by billionaire gotta
madani said the report is full of
baseless allegations
Ben foldi covers financial and business
issues for the Wall Street Journal and
explains what you need to know
see Donnie group is a collection of
companies they run ports they run
airports they run coal powered power
plants they run coal terminals basically
all the things that you kind of need to
build a fast-growing developing economy
like India and inbeg research looks for
companies that they allege or frauds or
have accounting issues and they then bet
against the stock and then they publish
the research showing their allegations
hoping that it will go down they were
largely responsible for almost
everything that happened with a company
called Nikola which led to the founder
being indicted on fraud charges and
convicted last year in one of the
biggest cases of that type in recent
history hannenberg's allegations about
adani are largely around a network of
offshore companies the day alleged are
tied to the adani family or their
Associates that they use to manipulate
the stock
the report is a malicious combination of
selective misinformation stale baseless
and discredited allegations that have
been tested and rejected by India's
highest courts adani responded with a
413 page report what was interesting
about the response is that it opened on
this note of Indian Nationalism which
really kind of points to a defense
strategy for the company but also it
points to the company's identity as
being part and parcel of
the Indian growth story the fundamentals
of our company
are very strong
our balance it is healthy
and assets
robust
we will continue to focus
on a long term value creation
and growth
and Donnie has already suffered quite a
bit 100 billion dollars in market cap is
nothing to seize at to have something
move the market this much within a
couple days is pretty remarkable